bon c'est vrai
d'après
dès que je passais juste par là en fait
parce que je venais chercher des
aubergines pouvoir est bon soir à tout
cela est si bon chemin
ah non moi même j'ai joué 48 coucou à
gérer nadia a ici pas de l'émission font
pas partie de l'équipe et moi non plus à
la base un voulait trouver changée
t'es pas là dessus
ça y est la personne est passée de coach
à ça mais on aime bien rouler bien mais
c'est très beau ça va et thomas n'gijol
ça semblait vous avez vu ce qu'elle a
dit que vous alliez être césarisé ouais
bah écoute comme on dit xala je sers mon
ordi des conneries dans cette émission
un truc c'est pas un truc de brocante
genre dans le pont sli 6 à 13 ans dans
ton c'est assez sympa la brocante à
présent dont on sait la monster est oui
senna est le mec il est persuadé rire
koh lanta j'embrasse mokhtar merci vous
manqués en tout cas les cherry et je
voudrais dire justin tu es super merci
franchement je kiffe je donne tu m'as vu
tu as vu mon nom j'ai pas que buju dia
hollandais argentine à 22 ans
vous
vous manquez nouvelle fois
salut
gianni motti pousser les foules